stay gay ASMR there it is
welcome the next level kitchen where
we're going to show you the tips and
recipes that could make you a Next Level
chef and today we're going to cook up
some amazing pork chops and classic
Protein that's right there's really
nothing quite like pork and we're going
to show you how to take it to the next
level by showing you two different ways
to make it incredible but before we
start cooking let's talk about the most
important element oil I'm making a pork
schnitzel and I'm gonna actually shallow
or pan fry that in grapeseed oil I like
to use grapeseed oil peanut oil is also
amazing for frying and I'm flavoring my
grapeseed oil which is a neutral oil
with a pretty fairly high smoke point
with some pork fat that I've taken off
just from the fat cap of this pork
listen whatever you cook your ingredient
in it's going to help flavor it right so
you've added more pork flavor to this by
cooking that fat in the oil maybe you
don't have an extra fat cap of pork
laying around but you might have bacon
underneath your sink you can cook in the
Bacon fat or like I'm going to do I'm
going to fry my pork chop in ghee or
clarified butter which has a high
smoking point so I'm going to get the
flavor of butter but I'm not gonna burn
my butter okay so you're making a
schnitzel you got some work to do over
there I am so I'm gonna actually start
out with uh the pounding out of the pork
you can totally use a rolling pin or any
heavy bottom pot as well I'm using
something called a mallet here a really
fun great tip if you plan on sort of
flattening any protein or vegetable is
to use a double-sided cling film so this
is literally just a piece of cling film
that I've wrapped on top of itself and
then folded in half and what that's
going to do is give me a nice sturdy
base so my plastic cling film doesn't
break and I hate to jump in there but
maybe you're in the basement level and
you don't have a mallet but you have
another pan that you can use as a mallet
absolutely never let equipment stop you
from doing it 100 so uh yeah heavy
bottom paw a rolling pin anything that
it has a heavy weight to it will work
great so today I'm using what is called
a mallet and so the most important thing
when uh attempting to flatten out any
protein is to push away from you right
so I'm pulling towards myself and I'm
also pushing away and what that is doing
is just breaking up those muscle fibers
you have a sort of rougher side that's
going to help tenderize and pull out but
you see I'm just rotating a bit
and I'll continue to push out and pull
towards me and that's going to create a
nice wide flat surface what you got
going on over there Rich okay I love it
I'm gonna you know start on um the
things that take the longest to cook
just like I'm telling our chefs in the
kitchen I'm making these Hasselback
Potatoes right uh very very trendy but
not just trendy absolutely delicious so
to make them I've just skewered my
potatoes and then very very finely I'm
just taking my knife and I'm sort of
just making these little inserts in them
so that what I'm doing is cutting into
the potato so that they're going to get
nice and crispy right and I'm also going
to fry those potatoes so a little bit of
this clarified butter like I said on
these trays and I'm gonna pop my
potatoes off of the skewer once I have
them cut just put them in the oven and
I'm frying potatoes in butter which
sounds and is absolutely delicious so
it's delicious the oil that you're that
you're cooking in is going to flavor the
dish I love olive oil but it's not the
perfect oil for everything you want to
cook in Bacon Fat lamb fat if you're
roasting a chicken at home save the
drippings from that chicken put it in a
little ice cube tray pop it in the
freezer cook your salmon in it the next
day that's how you win next level Chef
okay you're pounding out the Schnitzel I
love that tip about pounding it away
from you exactly super super smart yeah
so it's not just about flattening it and
hacking away uh it's really about
working with intentionality again as we
always tell our chefs right it's about
everything has a purpose and a reason
right so I want a nice flat round
surface so I'm working towards that
okay I'm over here I'm going to make a
little bit of coleslaw I have some red
cabbage and I'm what I'm going to do is
just really sort of shave some of this
red cabbage for my slaw so uh I shift a
knot if you will which means really
really thin like hair I'm just gonna
make a nice bright dish because it's
going to be a roasted pork chop over
here a pan-fried pork chop and what I
want is a lot of this nice texture uh
coming through you know I like contrast
of texture when I'm cooking something
that's crispy something that's soft
right that's how you get to the next
level I love it and you can like really
go in and kind of build your perfect
bite so that's what I'm all about
okay so I have my cabbage in the bowl
real quick this is the simplest slaw
that you're ever gonna make I'll just
have the red cabbage you can use
whatever color cabbage you want but I
think red cabbage and pork works really
really well a little bit of sesame oil a
splash of vinegar I'm gonna throw some
cilantro in there as well
um of course anytime I'm seizing
anything I want I want some salt and
pepper in there season from up high get
all of that in there and that's very
simple that's my slaw I'll toss in some
cilantro another thing about cilantro I
love these stems are really really
delicious like you can eat the stems
don't throw them away like there are
some herbs parsley sometimes can be a
little bit chewy but I'm just going to
take the whole the whole pieces of the
cilantro throw it into my slaw how are
you doing over there Naisha I have my
pork fat rendering here and now I have
my pork pounded out and what I'm gonna
do is create a little bit of a breading
station right and this is something that
whenever you're attempting to fry or uh
in fancy kitchens we call penne standard
breading procedure you want flour right
we need the batter or whatever you're
coating your protein or vegetable with
it needs something to stick to right if
you went straight into egg wash and then
into breadcrumbs there'll be too much
steam that creates a barrier and your
batter won't have anything to stick to
or create that glue so what I want to do
is first essentially go into a seasoned
flour I've seasoned my flour simply with
some black pepper a little bit of salt
and some Smoky paprika then what I do is
lightly toss that into my seasoned flour
I've simply whipped up some eggs again
I've added a pinch of salt right
seasoning as you go is very important
and it adds up at the end right so you
don't have to add too much salt at the
very end so now
tossed my pounded out pork chop into
I've tossed my pork chop into my
seasoned flour and then I just lightly
toss into my egg mixture
tap on the side and then I'm going to go
into my panko
right and you want to keep one hand for
your wet one hand for your dry and
that's what gives you the adherence
right that's what's going to allow our
panko to
stick onto the actual pork itself and
then I'm just going to go straight into
this beautiful cast iron pan what do you
got going on okay yeah so I'm gonna pan
fry I have a clarified butter or ghee
you can buy it in the store again it's
butter where the milk solids have been
removed so that the butter is not going
to burn but I'm still going to get that
buttery flavor I have my bone-in shop
I've seasoned it with salt pepper and
I'm going to add a little bit of five
spice to it which to me just reminds me
of the holidays and the fall and you
have the cinnamon and the star anise and
the fennel and the clove all of that
stuff in there so I have my pork chops
seasoned really really well when you're
cooking you want the meat to actually
come to room temperature before you put
it in the pan so a lot of people think
it has to come right from the fridge you
don't want that and then anytime we're
cooking a piece of meat a red meat steak
a pork chop like this it's got a big
bone on it you want to see this right
here right you see the smoke on a pan
you know that the pan is hot enough and
then you do a little bit of steak ASMR
do you like ASMR I'm a big fan so as
somebody a little bit like this
steak ASMR there it is like a sizzling
steak in a pan so now I'm gonna cook
that I have my slaw got my potatoes in
the oven and uh you're cooking your
schnitzel I'm cooking my pork chop uh
I'm gonna make a quick sauce are you
doing a sauce over there yeah so I've
dropped my pork chop into my uh shallow
fry right that's really the important
thing is different ways to approach
frying or uh you know cooking different
styles of protein right this has more
spices on it you don't want as much oil
you want some coloration this I want a
little bit more of that sort of frying
Viber technique and again every
opportunity for flavor so as my bread
crumbs start to caramelize around the
outside or turn a little bit of that
golden brown delicious color I'm going
to add a little bit of of a hard herb
right so thyme oregano Rosemary these
are examples of hard herbs and again
with that pork fat that's just hanging
out rendering off the side essentially
making a chicharron and this is another
flavor opportunity to season the oil
right every opportunity in cooking is a
chance for flavor right so
simply going in turning over that pork
chop and uh and then I'm just gonna
baste it a little bit right because I
really want some nice even golden brown
color I don't want my oil too hot right
because I don't want that pork to seize
up too much right so I just want nice
and a good indicator is really the small
bubbles right that's what's going to
tell you how hot your oil is you want to
look at the bubbles right
how's your pork Chef my pork chop is
ready to sort of flip over here how do
you know that it's ready to flip how do
you know you look at it you just gotta
look at it is it golden brown and
delicious it's absolutely golden brown
and delicious I'm gonna flip it over and
as it's gonna finish cooking in the pan
similar to what Naisha is doing over
there what I want to do now is I started
it in the clarified butter which isn't
going to burn but as I'm getting ready
to finish this chop I'm gonna throw some
butter in the pan and I'm literally
gonna throw it in a pan because now
usually this is what I do when I'm home
yeah okay you backed away which is
really really smart but you got to be
gotta get you gotta get the butter toss
going
so bad so bad but I got one in there I
got one in there hard herbs right in the
pan
and then it's going to be base base just
like you're doing I love that just like
you're doing it that's what that was one
of my favorite parts of cooking on the
line is the base yeah it wasn't throwing
butter in the pan No that too I mean
whenever there's opportunity for sports
and activities I'm a big fan um so I'm
actually just gonna serve my pork
schnitzel with a little potato salad
really simple smooth Dijon mustard go
crazy you can use whole grain Dijon
mustard if you would like the world is
your oyster good olive oil as Chef
Richard mentioned different oils have
different applications so olive oil
doesn't have as high of a smoke point so
I wouldn't want to start my pork chop by
cooking with it but I do want all of
that beautiful robust olive oil flavor
in by way of a vinaigrette right so I'm
going to toss some beautiful pre-cooked
fingerling potatoes here with some
really good high quality olive oil some
smooth Dijon mustard a little bit of
salt
and just some fresh dill right I think
with potato salad it's nice and again as
Richard said you don't need to go in
with a fine-tooth comb and pick out all
of the stems you know some of those
stems are delicious and add really
phenomenal texture and flavor and you
don't need to go too fancy right I'm
just doing whole potatoes here and
really just going to toss this together
with some acid coming from my lemon
juice
okay we're doing good so my pork Chop's
just about done that's gonna rest which
is really important maybe not as much
for the Schnitzel but definitely for a
chop that's on the bone you want it to
rest as long as it Cooks right you know
who told me that Gordon Ramsay can you
believe it Gordon Ramsay Gordon Ramsay
thing I'm gonna make my sauce this is
one of my favorite simple sauces pork
chops and applesauce works really really
well but I'm gonna take applesauce and a
little bit of white miso which is salty
it's got a lot of uh Umami to it and
it's gonna be white miso yellow mustard
and then uh some applesauce right so
literally three things that are in
containers uh and there it is this is
the glaze for my pork chop it's really
really simple mustard apple sauce miso
all things that I know work incredibly
well with pork you're just basy basty
basty over there looks great my Fork is
totally done now love it pull that out
and let it rest like I said and again
the basting is really just to provide
even color right I I've reached a very
beautiful Peak um expression of that
golden brown and delicious we eat with
our eyes this side is a little bit less
color on it so it's an opportunity to
get the very beautiful side out of the
oil and I'm really just essentially
cooking one side right that's really the
point of the basting it's develop that
color and also cook the pork and raise
the temperature on the inside as well
okay there it is I have my mustard glaze
it's gonna go just right on top of this
pork
and this is going to be one it's a glaze
but it's also the sauce for this oh I
love that I love the flavor of Dijon
mustard and miso together
me too you know what I love about it too
and listen we've cooked competitively
before 100 everyone at home you're also
cooking competitively maybe you don't
have a platform dropping in your kitchen
but you got to get food on the table in
less than 30 minutes right absolutely uh
find things that work really really
quickly in this case again it's that
pork chop it's applesauce and it's miso
and it's right there on my plate you're
going to the plate wow our timing we're
sinking up yeah so I'm gonna pull my
pork chop out and really the most
important thing when frying is to season
directly when it comes out you really
want that salt to go inside and flavor
when the oil is hot inflating this dish
really simple
these are simple potato salad I love
with schnitzel to serve it with a fresh
slice of lemon really helps cut through
the fattiness of the the richness coming
from the pork
and I don't want to over complicate this
right slice the potatoes down if you'd
like this is the kind of dish I love to
serve family style
all right I love that and we're kind of
going the same way here this is how I'm
plating especially when I'm at home I
want to respect all of the things that I
cooked I have my pork chop and sauce
right over here I have my Hasselback
potatoes and then of course because we
don't want the cold item to get to get
warm right before I'm finished I'm gonna
just do a mound of this slaw Mama right
next
to my pork chop get a little height on
there again I love the fact that there's
a stem in there that's one of my
favorite things to eat in the world over
there any sort of schnitzel oh I can't
wait till you try it so yeah I'm just
gonna slice this down a bit again I'm
serving this one family style so it
gives everyone an opportunity to eat
this straight out of the fryer right I
don't want anything to have an
opportunity to chill down too much you
want to rest a little bit again very
important seasoning directly when it
comes out of the hot oil and so this
will go on simply plated and why not use
those crispy herbs right nothing goes to
waste so just finishing with some
beautiful crispy herbs and of course the
fresh slice of lemon look at these two
absolutely delicious versions of pork
right there all right there we go your
pork schnitzel
my pork with a blaze glaze Blaze I kind
of want to trade that's how you make a
Next Level dish to get ingredients and
more details on the recipes from today
check the description below and be sure
to subscribe for more episodes of Next
Level kitchen